well thanks very much christos and
thanks for inviting me to be here today
physics is a very broad subject
and not so easy to characterize
but it should be uncontroversial to say
that three of the most exciting
frontiers
in human knowledge
are these three explored in contemporary
physics
the short distance frontier the
properties
of elementary particles and their
interactions
the long dust distance frontier the
origin
and large scale structure of the
universe and a third just as compelling
and important the complexity frontier
the emergent phenomena that can occur
in systems that have many parts or many
particles
and in recent years there has arisen
a field at the interface
of computer science physics and
information theory
relating to the complexity frontier the
lens of computer science can be
fruitfully applied to all three of these
themes but it's especially well suited
for the study of complexity
this field is quantum information
science and then we explore
a frontier
previously perhaps not as well
recognized as it should have been
of highly complex quantum states which
we can call the entanglement frontier
and in this subject we address the
question
is it possible to control complex
quantum systems and if we can
what are the implications for science
and for technology
in quantum information science we are
rebelling against something we were
taught in school
a dichotomy between the
macroscopic world which can be described
by classical physics and the microscopic
world for which we need quantum
mechanics
we are hoping to realize profoundly
quantum behavior in large and complex
systems now why would we want to do that
the succinct answer is because
classical systems cannot simulate
quantum systems efficiently
that's something that we can't currently
prove either experimentally or
mathematically but we have good reason
to believe that it's true and that
propels us to try to scale up quantum
systems
but whether we'll succeed is still
unknown
to achieve really scalable quantum
physics
we need to overcome a formidable enemy
what we call decoherence which makes
under typical circumstances big systems
want to behave classically
and a question still looming over the
subject is will defeating decoherence be
merely really really hard so after a few
decades of hard work will succeed or
could it be so ridiculously hard that it
will take centuries to succeed if we
ever do
but anyway if we do succeed we can
envision the emergence of an era of
quantum supremacy where sufficiently
complex quantum systems will behave in
ways
that can't be predicted with our digital
computers ways that will surpass
understanding in a sense and therefore
surprise us and delight us
to
enter that era we need a better
understanding of two questions for which
computer scientists are particularly
well equipped to contribute what are the
quantum tasks which are feasible with
reasonable resources and what are the
quantum tasks that are hard to simulate
classically or maybe it will turn out
for reasons that are still
not clear that we'll never be able to
unleash these exponential resources
which quantum systems seem to be
capable of carrying
so there's already a compelling agenda
from the point of view of pure science
to push
against this entanglement frontier
but there's also a technological
incentive we all know that information
technologies of the future will be new
technologies that we can't exactly
imagine today
but it's interesting to speculate about
future technologies maybe i'm not the
ideal person to do that because i'm not
an engineer i'm a theoretical physicist
and maybe not particularly knowledgeable
about how computers work
but as a physicist i know without
hesitating that the greatest
intellectual achievement of the past
century has been the development of
quantum theory
and it's natural to wonder how the
emergence of quantum theory in the 20th
century is going to impact
21st century technology quantum theory
is not such a new subject anymore but
only relatively recently have we begun
to appreciate some of the ways in which
quantum systems are different from
classical systems having to do
especially with
the physics of information
information after all is something that
we can encode in the state of a physical
system like the pages of a book but
fundamentally all physical systems are
quantum systems
so information is something that we can
encode and store in a quantum state and
physicists have recognized for a long
time that information carried by quantum
systems can have some famously
counter-intuitive properties that's why
we proudly speak about the weirdness of
quantum theory
and only relatively recently are we
taking more seriously the idea that it's
possible to put the weirdness to work to
use the unusual properties of quantum
information to perform tasks that
wouldn't be possible if this were a less
weird classical world
and that desire to put weirdness to work
has driven the emergence of this field
quantum information science which
derives a lot of its intellectual
vitality from three central ideas which
i want to explain in more detail in the
talk quantum entanglement quantum
computing and quantum era correction
so in
the case of classical information we
know we can express it in terms of bits
we can think of a bit as an object like
a ball which can be either one of two
colors and you can store a bit in a box
and later on when you open the box
the color ball that you put in comes out
again so you can recover your bit and
read it
quantum information that is information
stored in a quantum state can also be
decomposed into
indivisible units what we call qubits or
quantum bits and for many purposes it's
helpful to envision a cubit as a colored
object inside a box but where now we can
open the box through either one of two
complementary doors corresponding to
different ways to prepare or measure the
state of a qubit
i can put information in either door
number one or door number two and then
later on if i open that same door again
the color ball that i put in
comes out again just as though the bit
were classical
but if i store information through door
number one of a qubit and then i measure
the complementary observable by opening
door number two then what comes out is
intrinsically random and unpredictable
even though we know exactly how the
qubit was prepared we can't predict what
will be found when we open the
complementary door
one consequence of that can be
appreciated if we think about copying
the quantum information if we could copy
a qubit that would mean that if i happen
to have stored information in door
number one
then if i open door number one of the
original and the duplicate the color
ball that i put in should come out of
both boxes
and similarly if i happen to have stored
information in door number two
then if i open door number two of the
original and the duplicate the color i
put in should come out of both boxes
but in fact there's no such physical
physically realizable machine we can't
with perfect fidelity copy unknown
quantum states and the reason is that
the copier has to probe inside the box
and if it uses the right door it can
copy the information as though it were
classical but if it opens the wrong door
it will damage the information and it
won't be possible to make a high
fidelity copy so
although we might be able to clone a
sheep we can't clone a cubit
now there are lots of possible physical
realizations of qubits i'll mention some
others later but if you want something
concrete to think about for the time
being you can imagine a single photon or
particle of light
with the polarization the direction in
which its electric field points which
can be either
horizontal or vertical corresponding to
these two states that we find to be open
door number one
and polarizations which are rotated by
45 degrees corresponding to
door number two so if we prepare a
horizontally
polarized photon and then measure along
these rotated axes
the outcome will be a random bit
the really interesting ways in which
quantum information is different from
classical information can be appreciated
only
if we consider more than one qubit so
imagine we have two they could be far
apart from one another one at caltech
the other in the custody of my friend
and the andromeda galaxy and some time
ago both of these qubits were both on
earth and they were prepared in a state
with some interesting properties
namely i can open my box in pasadena
through either door number one or door
number two and either way what i find is
just a random bit
and the same thing is true for my friend
and andromeda we prepared many
identical pairs of qubits and in every
case
when i open my door either one or two
and my friend opens his we just find
random bits so that means neither one of
us acquires any information
by opening the box that seems funny
because with two qubits we should be
able to store two bits of information
where is that information hidden
the answer here is that the information
is entirely in the correlations between
the qubits because it turns out for this
particular state that if my friend and i
open the same door we both find a random
bit but we find the same value of the
bit
when we both open door number one it
could be red or could be green but it's
always the same and that's also true if
we both open door number two
so there are really four distinguishable
ways in which a qubit in pasadena could
be correlated with a qubit
in andromeda we could find either the
same color or different colors when we
both opened door number one or door
number two we've chosen one of those
four ways that's two bits of information
which are encoded in the pair of boxes
but what's unusual is that information
is completely inaccessible locally you
can't
distinguish those four states from one
another just by opening the box in
pasadena and andromeda
the correlations
the information is entirely encoded in
the correlations between these two
distantly separated boxes and that
property of quantum information that can
be stored in correlations
is what we call quantum entanglement
it's really the crucial way in which
quantum information is different from
classical information of course
correlations are not a new thing we
encounter them all the time
usually my socks are the same color so
you can look at one of my feet and then
you know already without looking what
color sock you'll find on the other foot
and it's kind of like that with the
boxes if i want to know what my friend
is going to see when he opens door
number one in andromeda i can open door
number one in pasadena likewise if i
want to know what he would see if he
opened door number two i can open door
number two
it's almost the same thing but it's not
the boxes really are not like the soxes
and the essence of the difference is
that there's just one way to look at a
sock but there are these two
complementary ways to open a box and
that means that the correlations among
qubits
are richer and a lot more interesting
than correlations among bits
this idea of quantum entanglement was
first explicitly discussed by einstein
podolski and rosen in a paper in 1935
and to einstein quantum entanglement
seemed so unsettling as to indicate that
something was missing from our current
understanding of quantum physics and
that paper
excited some interesting reactions
including one that was particularly
insightful by schrodinger who put it
this way the best possible knowledge of
a whole does not necessarily include the
best possible knowledge of its parts
what schrodinger meant was that even if
we have the most complete description of
that pair of qubits that nature will
allow we're still powerless to predict
what will happen when we open a box in
either pasadena or andromeda and it was
schrodinger who suggested using the word
entanglement to describe this peculiar
quantum correlation and he also made the
point that it's rather discomforting
that the theory should allow a system to
be steered or piloted into one or the
other type of state at the
experimenter's mercy in spite of his
having no access to it what schrodinger
meant is it seems to be up to me to
decide by opening door number one or
door number two in pasadena whether i'll
be able to predict what my friend finds
when he opens door number two or door
number uh one in andromeda but
schroedinger also understood that these
correlations don't allow instantaneous
communication between pasadena and
andromeda
when we open the box locally we just
find a random bit we open either door
and so there's no information that's
locally accessible therefore no
communication
the theory of entanglement didn't
advance very much for about 30 years
until in the 1960s
starting with john bell we began to
think about entanglement in a different
way not just as something weird but as a
resource that can be used to do things
that wouldn't otherwise be possible
bell described games like this one in
which there are two players cooperating
both trying to win the game
and under the rules of this game alice
and bob each receive inputs and they are
to produce outputs which are correlated
in a certain way that depends on the
inputs that they receive
but
the rules of the game say that alice and
bob are not allowed to communicate
between the time that they receive the
inputs and produce the outputs they are
allowed to use correlated bits that
might have been prepared before the game
began and for this particular game if
they play the best possible strategy
they can win with a probability of
success of 75 averaged over the inputs
they could receive
but if alice and bob actually had
entangled qubits quantum correlations
that were distributed before the game
began then they can play a quantum
strategy which has a higher probability
of successfully winning the game a
little bit above 85 percent so the
quantum entanglement can be used to do
something win the game
better than we can do it just with
classical correlations
and experimental physicists have been
playing been playing this game for over
30 years now and they keep winning with
the probability above 75 percent so
these strong quantum correlations do
seem to be part of the way nature
behaves
einstein have derided quantum
entanglement calling it spooky action at
a distance and that sounds even more
derisive when you say it in german
but
a wonderful thing about physics is it
doesn't matter what einstein's opinion
is nature is as nature reveals her as
experiments reveal her to be and we have
to learn to love her as she is
so really the boxes are not like the
soxes you can win a game with a higher
probability with entanglement than you
can with classical correlations is that
really such a big deal
yeah that is really quite a big deal and
to understand why
it's helpful to consider systems with
many parts but first let's just
summarize what i've said so far about
the difference between quantum and
classical on the one hand there's
intrinsic randomness in the classical
world when we open a box even if we know
a complete description of what's inside
the box we can't necessarily predict the
outcome there's uncertainty because
opening door number one can
interfere with opening door number two
and there's entanglement in other words
the hole can be in a more definite state
than the parts
and if i consider a system with many
parts let's say it's a book if it were a
classical book 100 pages long there'd be
print on every page that we could read
and after we've read 10 pages we'd know
10 percent of the content of the book
but suppose it's a quantum book where
the pages are very highly entangled with
one another then we could read 10 pages
and we'd know
almost nothing about the content of the
book
because the information isn't printed on
the individual pages the information is
almost entirely in the correlations
among the pages and to read the book you
have to make a collective observation on
many
pages at once
so if we have a system with a modest
number of qubits just a few hundred if
we wanted to give a complete description
if it's a highly entangled state of 300
qubits of all the correlations among the
qubits when we open door number one or
door number two we'd have to write down
a
vector in a hilbert space which has
dimension 2 to the 300 we have to write
down more numbers than the number of
atoms in the visible universe so it'll
never really be possible even in
principle to write such a description
down and that was very intriguing to
richard feynman it led him to
note in the early 1980s that perhaps
if we could build a quantum computer
that processes qubits instead of
classical bits we'd be able to perform
tasks that aren't possible with
classical information processing
feynman's idea was that if we can't even
write down in terms of classical bits
the content of a few hundred qubits then
perhaps by processing the qubits we can
perform tasks that can't be simulated
classically
and at the time feynman was making this
suggestion
there was an undergraduate at caltech
studying mathematics
peter shore like all caltech sophomores
took a course on quantum physics and as
far as i know that was the most advanced
course on quantum physics that he took
but like many cal tech undergraduates he
remembered what he learned and he drew
upon it some years later to make a
remarkable discovery
an example of a problem that we think is
hard for classical computers is finding
the
prime factors of a large composite
integer
and sure discovered that with quantum
computers if and when we succeed in
building them
factoring is an easy problem it's not
much harder than multiplying numbers
together
and when i first heard about this in
1994 i was really quite awestruck
because i realized that it meant that
the difference between hard problems and
easy problems problems that we expect to
be able to solve with advanced
technologies and the problems that we'll
never be able to solve
that boundary is different than it
otherwise would be because this is a
quantum world
not a classical world i thought was that
was one of the most interesting
ideas i had heard in my life and it led
me to redirect my own research toward
quantum computing
so to give you an idea about what the
statement is about resource scaling we
can nowadays factor say a 193 digit
number if we use a few hundred
workstations collaborating over the
internet but with that same hardware and
algorithm it would take longer than the
age of the universe to factor a 500
digit number
let's suppose we had a quantum computer
with the same clock speed as that
classical system able to perform the
same number of operations elementary
operations per second
then we'd be able to factor 193 digit
number in a tenth of a second and a 500
digit number in two seconds so there's a
vastly different scaling of the
resources needed to solve the problem
with the quantum computer compared to
doing the calculation in the classical
world
does anybody care about factoring yes of
course a lot of people do because the
widely used
protocols for public key cryptography
are
based on the difficulty of factoring and
other
related problems when quantum computers
are widely available we won't be able to
use the same protocols for protecting
our privacy say when we make a purchase
over the internet
we'll have to protect our privacy in
other ways and alternatives exist but
it's still not entirely clear how we
will ensure privacy in the post-quantum
world
the more important thing is that shaw
and
bernstein and vance irani and others
taught us that there's an interesting
class of problems the problems which
are hard for classical computers but
which we think would be easy
for quantum computers and we are
compelled to understand better what
problems lie in that class
as best we understand the problems for
which quantum computers can achieve
spectacular speedups have to have a
special structure well
suited to the
what a quantum computer is capable of
problems like factoring other number
theoretic problems problems like
computing certain topological invariants
of manifolds and links
we don't expect quantum computers to
achieve spectacular speed ups for
np-complete problems like 3sat they can
perform exhaustive search faster than
classical computers but not
exponentially
faster but it's also important to
emphasize that there are problems that
are not in np that quantum computers are
particularly well suited for problems
for which we can't necessarily check the
solution with a classical computer and
the natural application for a quantum
computer is to simulate
the evolution of complex quantum systems
like large molecules or the quantum
field theories that we use to describe
elementary particles we wouldn't be able
to check that with a classical computer
but one quantum computer could check
another or we could do the check by
comparing with an experiment
in fact we believe that if we want to
simulate quantum field theory which is
used to explore
the
short distance frontier of physics in
some cases we don't
have the capability of performing
computations of the predictions of
quantum field theory on classical
computers when the theory is strongly
coupled and the system is very highly
entangled
but we do believe a quantum computer
would be able to simulate the physics of
a quantum field theory with resources
that scale
reasonably
with
uh parameters for the size of the input
like the number of particles uh the
total energy and the precision that
we're trying to attain
so much of physics can be efficiently
simulated if we have a quantum computer
although we don't know how to do it with
the classical computer a major open
question is what about processes in
which at very short distances gravity is
important we don't know whether a garden
variety quantum computer would be able
to simulate such processes
anyway quantum computers would be
uh very impressive and
interesting to play with uh we are
driven to build them so why don't we
have them already
what's the holdup well you see it's
really really really hard
and part of the reason it's hard is that
quantum computers are much more
susceptible to the damaging effects of
noise than ordinary classical computer
physicists like to talk about
a cat which we can imagine being
prepared in a superposition of the
live and dead state of the cat and we
never see in our everyday experience
that type of superposition of
macroscopically distinguishable states
the reason why not is that a real cat
will always
interact in an uncontrolled way with its
environment and those interactions will
in effect measure the cat and project it
onto the state which is completely dead
or completely alive
and that phenomenon which we call
decoherence is really important for
helping us to understand why even though
the underlying world is quantum
mechanical the world of our experience
is a classical world
uh it's because macroscopic systems
cannot be well isolated from the
environment and those interactions make
the system behave classically
a quantum computer won't be much like a
cat except that like a cat it too will
unavoidably interact with its
environment although we may try very
hard to prevent that and that will lead
to the failure of a quantum computation
so we have to find a way of protecting a
quantum computer from noise if we're
going to successfully operate one
of course as we well know noise is a
problem even in the classical world
everybody has bits that uh he or she
cherishes
everywhere there are dragons lurking who
delight and tampering with the bits
but we know that we can protect
classical information by storing it
redundantly
i can if i want to protect a bit
store some backup copies of the bit
that's a very simple code so that if the
dragon comes along and changes the color
of one of the balls then a busy beaver
can be employed to check that all the
balls are the same color and recolor the
odd one and then if the dragon hasn't
had a chance to damage two of the balls
we can recover the information without
any damage and we'd like to use the same
idea in the quantum world that
redundancy allows us to protect
information but it's not so simple
because remember we can't clone quantum
states we can't store backup copies of
unknown quantum states and there are
more things that can go wrong in the
quantum world than in the classical
world
a dragon could open door number one of a
box and change the color of the ball
that would be like a bit flip in the
classical world
but instead the dragon might open door
number two and change the color of the
ball that's what we call a phase error
in the cupid it doesn't have a classical
analog
there's another way of thinking about
the phase errors
it might be that instead of flipping the
color of the ball the dragon can open
door number one and observe and remember
the color of the ball that too will
cause an error if we open the box
through door number two and because it's
typically
easier to remember
the value of a qubit than to flip the
bit
these phase errors are particularly
pervasive and hard to avoid in the
quantum systems that experimentalists
deal with
really the key to preventing decoherence
is we have to prevent the environment
from learning about the state of the
quantum computer during the computation
if we successfully operate a large scale
quantum computer then when we're done if
we ask the quantum computer what it was
doing in the middle of the computation
it should always answer
i forget
it's okay for the final result to be
publicly known and we can broadcast it
to all our friends but the quantum
computer won't work if the state that it
was in during the computation
becomes known we have to keep the
computation encrypted
and in fact we can do that and the trick
is to store the information in a highly
entangled form
even though we can't use
three qubits to store
a protected logical qubit we can protect
a
logical qubit if we have five physical
qubits we store the information in a
highly entangled state of the five
qubits in such a way that if the dragon
comes along and makes any observation he
wants
on one of the five qubits he doesn't
learn anything about the value of the
logical qubit he doesn't get any
information because the information
isn't in that qubit it's just like the
hundred page book the information is in
the correlations among qubits
and the beaver now can come along and
make collective measurements on the five
qubits which will reveal how the
correlations among the qubits have been
damaged and then can restore those
correlations without the beaver ever
finding out the value of the qubit and
therefore without damaging it so
we can redundantly store quantum
information in such a way that it can be
protected from damage using quantum
error correcting
codes i first met alexei katayev when he
came to caltech to visit for the first
time in 1997
and
the day that he gave his seminar
and i made these notes was one of the
most exciting days of my scientific life
because i realized that
katya was telling us about a
idea about quantum error correction
which is potentially
transformative what i learned from
kataya is the relationship between
quantum era correction and topology
mathematicians speak of topology when
they're considering properties of
objects which are left invariant when we
smoothly deform the objects and in the
case of a quantum computer we would like
the way the protected information is
encoded in the computer to remain
invariant if we deform
the quantum computer by introducing some
noise so we'd like to use some
topologically protected physical
interactions and such interactions have
been known for a while for example i can
transport an electron around a magnetic
flux tube and the quantum state of the
electron changes in a way that depends
on the flux enclosed in the tube even
though the electron never directly
encounters the magnetic field inside
and that change in the wave function is
in fact a topological invariant it is
not altered if we deform the trajectory
that the electron follows when it goes
around the flux tube the only thing that
matters is its winding number the number
of times it wraps around the flux tube
and there are more exotic such
topological interactions that can occur
in physical systems that have
uh two dimensions and point like
excitations that we call non-abelian
anions these systems have the property
that if there are many
particles distantly separated from one
another
there are many possible quantum states
of those n particles which locally look
identical so that if the environment is
probing the system locally it can't tell
one state from another the information
is encoded in a highly redundant
non-local way through entanglement which
makes it well protected against the
effects of noise and the information can
be manipulated by performing exchanges
of the particles
so we can envision operating a
topological quantum computer
in which we to initialize the computer
create some pairs of anions and then
process information by performing a
sequence of exchanges of the particles
so their world lines trace out a grade
in space-time
and then i'll
read out the computer by bringing the
particles together
pair-wise to see whether they'll
annihilate or not thank you
now the beauty of this idea
is that the computation is intrinsically
resistant to decoherence because the
information is encoded in a very
non-local way
invisible to an adversary who probes the
system locally so if we keep the
temperature low so there aren't any
unwanted anions around and we keep the
particles far apart from one another so
they can't interact except at the very
beginning and the very end of the
computation then as long as we execute
the right braid in space time the
computation will give the right answer
so that's how it works in theory what
physical system can we use to realize
this idea
there are several notions about that
but the one which seems most promising
at the moment makes use of another trick
that ketaya thought up that in a certain
kind of quantum wire an electron can
split into two halves
there are two types of superconducting
wire one is a conventional
superconductor but the other is a more
exotic variant on superconductivity
called the topological superconductor
and the boundary between these two
phases
is the locus of a localized object that
we call a myoronofermion
so if we add an extra electron to the
topological superconductor it dissolves
and disappears and becomes
non-locally stored through some change
in the state of the myrano fermions you
can think of them as like half electrons
but they carry no charge no spin nothing
that's locally observable
and experiments done in the last year or
two indicate that this type of splitting
of an electron in a topological
superconductor can be realized in
semiconductor
systems under uh the right
conditions although more experiments
will be needed to definitively establish
that that's what's really going on
can we
process information that's stored
through this splitting of electrons we
can by doing exchanges of the majorana
fermions the location of the majorana
fermion can be moved by adjusting some
voltage gates so i can introduce a
t-junction
of superconducting wires
and
park the majorana fermion around the
corner
move the
myronofermion on the right over to the
left and then unpark the first so that
we have exchanged the two particles and
that provides a means of processing
information
and many such exchanges can be used to
build up
a quantum computation this type of
experiment hasn't been done yet but
we're hopeful it will be done in the
next couple of years
when that is achieved it'll be a real
milestone for physics apart from any
long-term technological
implications
is that does that mean that we're going
to use these topological ideas to
operate a quantum computer well actually
that's far from clear
there are other types of quantum
hardware that are being developed and
i'll tell you about one which is timely
because it was developed by dave
weinland who received the most recent
nobel prize in physics shared with
another great experimentalist serge
garosh
weiland and others have developed the
ion trap quantum computer it makes use
of the technology originally developed
for making very good clocks
for trapping
charged atoms individual atoms that are
ionized so they have electric charge and
we can manipulate them with electric
fields they can be stored in a trap for
a very long time and we can think of
each ion as being in either one of two
quantum states either the ground state
or some long-lived metastable state of
the ion and although these are
individual atoms they're actually easy
to read out we can illuminate them with
laser light
and
if the frequency of the light is chosen
appropriately it interacts strongly with
ions in the red state so they glow
visibly and it doesn't interact with the
ions in the green state so they remain
invisible and in an iron trap the ions
are typically microns apart long enough
compared to the wavelength of visible
light so that they're easily resolved so
they're easily read out but we want to
do more than that we want to process the
information
and for that purpose we make use of the
electrostatic repulsion among the ions i
can pick out one ion in the trap and
shine on it a laser pulse whose
frequency and duration is chosen so that
nothing will happen if the ion starts
out in the red state but if it's in the
green state it undergoes a transition
and a vibrational mode of all the ions
in the trap is excited and then i can
pick out a second ion in the trap
and
address it with a pulse laser whose
frequency and duration is chosen so that
nothing will happen if the ions are not
vibrating but if they are that ion
undergoes a transition and the vibration
stops so what we've done is we picked
out two ions in the trap and if the
first ion had been red nothing would
have happened if the first one is green
both change color if we start out with a
superposition of red and green then
we've made an entangled state of the two
ions and many such entangling operations
can be put together to do a quantum
computation at least that's the cartoon
of how an ion trap works from a
theorist's point of view if you visit
weinland's lab
at nist and boulder colorado then you're
kind of in for shock there's a lot of
technical complexity underlying the
operation that i
just told you about it might discourage
you about the feasibility of scaling up
this technology but there are
interesting ideas about how it might be
done and people are working on it but
that's just one of a number of
approaches to building quantum hardware
which is currently being pursued
two others that are promising are ones
making use of superconducting technology
and the magnetic moments of electrons in
the case of superconducting circuits
although this isn't the best way to do
it for practical reasons we can imagine
storing a qubit
in the current in a small loop
circulating either clockwise or
counterclockwise and what's remarkable
about that encoding is that these are
really good qubits which can be
manipulated accurately even though from
a microscopic point of view they're
quite complex involving the motion of
billions of electrons
another approach is to use the spin or
magnetic moment of a single electron its
magnetic field can be oriented either
up or down to encode a qubit and what's
remarkable in that case is there we're
really just talking about a single
electron but it can be manipulated quite
accurately with existing technology
so these are just a few of the
approaches to
achieving quantum hardware that are
being pursued all of them have strengths
and weaknesses so it's not really clear
at this stage which will be the best
path to scalability
but to get an idea of how the current
state of quantum technology compares to
the classical
technology suppose we wanted to run
shore's algorithm and break rsa well you
could do that with classical computers
you just need a lot of parallelism
if you'd like to do it in 10 years then
you can cover one quarter of the land
area of north america
with a server farm at a cost of about a
million trillion dollars that would
consume about 10 to the fifth times the
world power output and the other bad
news is that we use up the world's
supply of fossil fuels in about
one day
john martinez who's
one of the leaders in developing
superconducting
uh
technology for quantum computing
compared that to what he could do with
his existing technology in his lab
well we need to have about 10 000
logical qubits but because of the
overhead of doing air correction
probably about 10 million physical
qubits to factor
the number and we put them far enough
apart from one another so that there's
room for lots of wires uh so that we
classically control them and currently
it costs martinez about ten thousand
dollars to make the physical qubit so it
would cost about 100 billion dollars but
he could run the algorithm in 16 hours
so we've got to bring the cost down a
little bit okay
well it's a little bit worse than that
we need better qubits and better
classical control than we currently have
it's not just a question of dollars but
at any rate is something that we can
envision
happening
in the coming decades whereas this looks
like a much tougher hall
now for any technology that we use we're
going to have to have quantum era
correction in order to get robust
operation and really the best idea that
we currently have about how to do
quantum error correction in a reasonably
efficient way is to use these
topological ideas to simulate a
topological medium using the physical
qubits that we can operate
accurately
that will only work if the physical
qubits have noise which is weakly
correlated and if the probability of
gate
probability of an error per gate in our
physical qubit system is sufficiently
small sufficiently small means well well
below a one percent probability of error
per gate according to
a current estimate and
with the uh ion trap and superconducting
technologies that currently exist error
rates are at about the one percent level
it'd be nice to improve that
by a factor of 10 but it's still going
to be really really hard as an
electrical engineering problem to scale
up these systems to sufficient size
to solve hard problems
so there are three questions about
quantum computers that we've talked
about why build one well one reason is
so that we'd be able to simulate a broad
variety of quantum phenomena in the
physical world can we build one well we
don't know of obstacles in principle
that'll prevent us from succeeding how
will we build one are there a lot of
approaches to quantum hardware being
developed and we don't know which will
be the most promising in the long run
building large-scale quantum computers
is already kind of a i think compelling
research agenda but i'm not an engineer
i'm
a theoretical physicist so what i find
particularly interesting are the ways in
which ideas about quantum information
are giving us fresh insights about
problems in physics and a lot of those
ideas have to do with what we call the
monogamy
of
quantum correlations
correlations in the classical world are
polygamous
adam and betty can read the same
newspaper they have the same information
and now they're correlated
but nothing prevents charlie from
reading the paper too and then charlie
is just as correlated with adam and with
betty as adam and betty are with one
another and the rest of us can read the
paper and
join the party quantum correlations are
different they're harder to share if
adam and betty are very strongly
entangled with one another betty uses up
her ability to entangle and isn't able
to be correlated with charlie at all
conversely if betty decides to entangle
with charlie
she doesn't have any capacity for
entanglement left to share with adam and
becomes uncorrelated with adam that
type of monogamy of entanglement can be
frustrating if betty would like to
entangle with both
adam and charlie she has to give up some
of her entanglement with adam in order
to entangle more with charlie and that
monogamy has very widespread
implications one important one is in
cryptography
adam and betty can use quantum
entanglement to generate a shared key
that can be used for encrypted
communication and if they verify that
they're really highly entangled by
winning bell's game for example then
they know that an adversary trying to
eavesdrop on their key won't be able to
get any information about it it's also
important in the study of quantum matter
because there are limitations on how
entangled the matter can be we have many
particles perhaps all of which want to
be entangled with other particles but if
a particle becomes entangled with one of
its neighbors that eliminates its
ability to entangle with other particles
and that is leading us to a better
understanding of how
quantum phases of matter can be
classified according to the nature of
their many body entanglement
and they've also been recent insights
into the physics of black holes coming
from thinking about monogamy let me tell
you a little bit about that black holes
have been causing us puzzlement for
decades because we know that because of
quantum effects black holes can
evaporate
and eventually disappearing completely
which raises the question of what
happens to the information that was
encoded in the matter that collapsed to
form the black hole
if black holes are like other thermal
objects that radiate then we would
expect that the information encoded in
the original collapsing body winds up
being emitted in some highly scrambled
form in the outgoing radiation but black
holes aren't like other
thermal objects because they have an
event horizon what that means is that
spacetime is very highly deformed so
that i can draw a single space-like
slice
which
represents a single time that crosses
both the collapsing body inside the
black hole and the radiation that's
emitted as it evaporates so if the
information is emerging in the radiation
that means the same quantum information
would be in two places at once that
would be cloning
so we're faced with an unbe palatable
choice either either the information
really gets destroyed
or cloning occurs and either way we have
to revise our understanding of quantum
physics so some years ago we suggested
the idea of black hole complementarity
to get out of this quandary that we
shouldn't think of the system inside the
black hole and outside the black hole as
two different
subsystems of a larger system but
instead they are complementary
viewpoints of the same system
so the information in the collapsing
body the information in the hawking
radiation are just two complementary
ways of looking at the same quantum
system for reasons which are quite
subtle and which we don't really
completely understand and therefore
cloning isn't occurring there are just
two ways of looking at things one is
appropriate for the observer who falls
into the black hole the other
appropriate for the one who stays
outside
so this idea of complementarity puts
together three beliefs all of which seem
to be very reasonable black holes just
scramble information they don't destroy
it
an observer who falls through a black
hole doesn't see anything unusual or
unexpected according to the laws of
physics at least not right away
eventually she hits the singularity
but when she crosses the horizon
everything seems normal and an observer
who stays outside the black hole just
sees the usual laws of physics but what
was pointed out
last year
by this group at santa barbara i'll
marry it all
is that we can't really cling to all
three of these beliefs
because we run into a conflict with the
monogamy of entanglement and they
propose giving up on number two so that
an observer who passes inside a black
hole doesn't
meet her doom later on when she
encounters the singularity but
dies an unexpected fiery death
immediately upon crossing the horizon
so why did they say that it's really
because of monogamy of entanglement
because there are three things that we
know
so one is that if information is not
destroyed by a black hole
then
when the black hole is old recently
emitted radiation by the time it escapes
from black hole will have to be highly
entangled
with radiation that was emitted earlier
on the other hand we know that the
vacuum and quantum field theory is a
very highly entangled
state so that means this recently
emitted radiation if an in-falling
observer doesn't see anything special
must be highly entangled with modes
inside the black hole behind the horizon
and finally if system b by the time it
gets out to system c is highly entangled
with system c then it must have been
highly entangled with system c
to
begin with if there's no unusual physics
outside the horizon so we got a problem
here because system b wants to be highly
entangled with system a and it also
wants to be highly entangled with system
c and that's not compatible with the
monogamy of entanglement
so one point of view we can take is that
well a and b aren't really so highly
entangled but that means we're far from
the vacuum that's the firewall scenario
in which the in falling observer burns
up maybe b and c are not so highly
entangled but that means information is
actually destroyed when a black hole
evaporates
or maybe b and c are entangled by the
time b escapes from the black hole but
were not entangled when
b was very close to the horizon but in
that case there's been some non-local
physics transferring the entanglement
outside the horizon and in this case we
don't seem to be able to use this
complementary viewpoint to get out of
our problem
because it seems that a single observer
would be able to verify both types of
entanglement if both existed so this is
all very confusing
i'm not sure what the right conclusion
is what the outcome of this will be but
i wanted to tell you about it because
this is an observation that could have
been made decades ago and the reason
it's only occurring now is that
physicists are becoming more accustomed
to thinking about physical processes
from an information processing point of
view and ideas about quantum computing
help to lead to this insight
well at caltech we have an institute for
quantum information and matter which is
devoted to probing the entanglement
frontier across a broad
front
spanning computer science and
various areas of physics and at the iqim
we have a slogan which is nature is
subtle
that
evokes the famous statement of einstein
that the lord is subtle but not
malicious in fact einstein
underestimated the subtlety of nature
when he
dismissed quantum entanglement as spooky
action at a distance
and in the study of quantum information
science we have the opportunity now to
relish explore and hopefully exploit the
glorious subtlety of the quantum world
in all its facets and ramifications
thanks for listening to me
um
so the question was about a recent
announcement by a company called
and what does it imply about the
ultimate sustainability quantum
computing well the leeway technology is
a very special type of quantum system
it's not or is it a general purpose
quantum computer
people are trying to calibrate the
it's really a kind of physical simulator
it simulates a physical process
which can be used to
find solutions to satisfiability
problems it's a simulation of a spin
glass in the
in a background magnetic field
and
it's an interesting technology
exactly what it's capable of is uh not
entirely clear so that'll require
further investigation but there are
reasons for
skepticism about its scalability and its
ability to solve
large instances
of hard problems it's a very noisy
system there's no fault tolerance built
into it
and it can't be controlled better than
something like 10
accuracy the qubits have very short
coherence times
and
there is some evidence that quantum
physics is relevant to its operation
uh that's something that's still being
studied
um
but uh i think
for many of us it would be a great
surprise if it turns out to be capable
of solving uh truly scalable problems
yeah i mean i think that's a uh
so when i said
perhaps uh
not for
uh centuries i
also added or ever
and in that case i was trying to cover
the possibility that because
of laws of physics that haven't yet been
discovered
the scalability of quantum computing
will fail at some point it's a very
interesting theoretical problem to try
to find
deformations away from standard quantum
mechanics which are compatible with the
things that we know but would lead to
the expectation that
in the long run quantum computing
won't be scalable and there's really no
very candidate theor very uh
serious uh theoretical proposal for that
type of model but i think it would be
very interesting to find one and that's
one of the strongest motivations i think
we have from the point of view of pure
science for seeing how far quantum
computing will go
yeah so the question was
can we learn useful lessons from the
study of quantum computing that could be
applied to classical systems like
complex network models including those
that are used to model the brain
as in the previous talk well i think
there are a number of ways in which
the tools of quantum computing and
quantum complexity can be
applied to
reaching conclusions
proving theorems
about purely classical computational
systems in the case of network models i
don't think
i know of any very concrete thing that
can be said
about
how the study of quantum complexity
relates to the capacity of classical
network models
uh yes
yeah so so the question was
perhaps inappropriately for this
audience
i described the hypothesis
that
quantum computers can solve problems
that classical computers
cannot in informal language what is the
corresponding
formal
statement and the question goes on to
propose such a formal statement which is
that the
complexity class that we call bqp
those
quantum computing is a type of
randomized computation so bqp means the
problems for which we can
you know with probability above
two-thirds
solve a
decision problem by operating a quantum
circuit or
really a uniform family of quantum
circuits and is the statement that that
would be greater
uh than bpp and yeah that's exactly the
statement
and it is widely believed i would say
but
like uh all attempts or well not quite
all but many attempts to separate
complexity classes it's a very hard
thing to prove
question over here
um
um
um
so the question
the the question
uh points out that it's been known for
some time
that
there's no difference between the
quantum and classical models as far as
the conclusion about
what
functions are computable
the notion of computability is the same
in the quantum world and the classical
world
in fact we can simulate a quantum
computer classically
and uh
that's the you know the the easy way to
see that there's no uh separation in
what's computable it's just a question
of resources so the statement about
um quantum computers being more powerful
concerns the problems that we can solve
with you know polynomial size uniform
quantum circuit families versus
uh classical ones and the question was
well where in fact do the
do things come together where did the
quantity how how far down to the quantum
and uh
and classical
um
worlds meet i mean that's a that's an
active subject of current research we
know that there are classical uh
complexity classes that uh contain this
class bqp p space for example and there
are some tighter bounds than that
but uh one question that's open is
whether about bqp lies in the polynomial
hierarchy
thank you